[inaudible] joining me today is the
founder and president of live action,
a pro life organization, which advocates
for the dignity of all human beings.
Lila rose,
welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me,
Dave. I'm glad to be here.
Well,
I'm glad to be here too.
You had reached out to me like a year
ago about having a civil conversation
about abortion.
Is that even remotely possible to do it?
We're going to do it. Are going to do it.
All right. We're going to see, because we,
we do, I think most people
watching this from the beginning,
just from the way I intro,
do you know that we have a,
a different position on this?
And that's okay.
I've had this debate
and this conversation,
I don't even want to call it a debate.
I've had this conversation with Ben
Shapiro and a series of other people. Um,
but this is the one, I mean, to me,
abortion is the one that is the most
polarizing and sort of just makes everyone
absolutely crazy. So let's put
it that there. And here we go.
So just tell me a little bit about
yourself. First before we get into this.
Sure. So I'm, I head up this
non profit, not for profit,
but that's most of my time in life.
But I'm also big into my family.
That's really important to me.
I've got married last fall and regulation
actually have seven siblings. Wow.
So really prolife yeah, my
parents were anyway. Yeah.
And then I live in Berkeley
right now. Berkeley, California,
born and raised in San Jose.
Wait a minute, wait a minute. What are
you doing up in Berkeley? A good time.
Are they okay with your alternative
lifestyle up in Berkeley?
It's, yeah, it is very
alternative. But you know what?
More people are open minded on this then
I think we give each other credit for,
because people just assume they,
they have like an opinion on it.
But once you start to engage and
have a conversation, people are,
people can be very open minded.
So there definitely are people that are
just kind of your stereotypical set in
their ways. This is my ideology, right?
I've had some really good
conversations in Berkeley.
So I think people find it really
interesting to see how people have either
evolved or not evolved or changed or
not changed when it comes to abortion.
Did you come from a family that was where,
I guess you just said your family was,
was prolife yeah.
Conservatives. Republicans.
Yeah, they would, I would, I definitely
think they identify as conservative.
They weren't necessarily activists.
So what, when I started live action,
I actually started as a teenager.
It was kind of an oddball thing because
they were not out there doing prolife
activate active activism are,
you know,
doing activism in any
really political kinds. Um,
but they were very
people that really cared.
My family really cared about peep other
people. They cared about education.
We were homeschooled,
so we had this alternative lifestyle.
They're kind of like hippies
in a different way because
they're all, you know,
big family homeschool. Um,
we, we had like chickens,
we've got some chickens
back. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can play with the chickens later.
I look forward to that. Yeah. So, okay,
so you've got into this topic.
I mean you started doing activism
related to abortion when you were in high
school? Yes. Yeah. How did
that possibly come to be?
Yeah, so we, we, again, it
was kind of alternatives.
I was actually taking like
college classes when I was 12.
Like we had a really kind of
mismatch or a patchwork education.
We did all kinds of, you know, where I
was going to some high school classes,
some college classes.
So there's a lot of free
time and flexibility in my
schedule and I had a lot of
passion and ability to
pursue things I loved.
And when I found out about abortion,
I was just very, very concerned. Um,
I was really interested in all kinds
of human rights issues. I was really,
you know, I was involved
in like volunteering with
children with disabilities,
volunteering with homeless ministry,
you know, house building and in Mexico,
in Tijuana, um, famine
relief in this year.
So I was really into just
wanting my life to be, you know,
stirrup give back.
And when I found out about abortion and
I started to really consider what was
happening. So there's 3000
abortions every day in America.
So that's a million a year.
And I started to look at the fetal
development and see just how amazing this
little life is even in the first
trimester that this is alive and just the
violence abortion does to that life.
And I was learning all this as like,
you know,
my early teens.
I was just deeply struck because I
thought if this is really life or be,
if these are really humans like you
and I are humans and you and I started,
you know, embryo Dave, you know,
back in the day and realize we all are
in the same year, very fashionable.
I'm sure. Yeah, I'm in Utero. But we all
started that way and I was just thinking,
I thought, I realized this is
the greatest human rights issue.
I can get involved in
a lot of other causes.
There's a lot of things to care about,
but this is life and death
for 3000 people a day.
And they're people that are
not protected by the law.
They're seen as society as less
than not human and women girls.
I mean as a woman and as a, as a young
woman, very young women at the time,
I just thought I'm being told that
taking this life is a good thing,
can be a really good thing for me.
And I just thought, how can this be?
This is a violence violent act.
So that really inspired me
just to begin live action.
And the idea was I just need to get a
group of friends together to do community
education.
Basically community organizing to educate
other young people in high school and
junior high about what
abortion actually is about.
Embryonic and fetal development
about the risks to women.
No one talks about the risks to women
about the way it's harmed society and how
this is not peace and justice.
This is actually violence and injustice.
And if we want to be better together
and be more loving and be more,
more compassionate, we need to eradicate
this all together from our society.
Okay. So I want to touch on a lot of
those issues that you just brought up.
So you start live action as
a, as a young teenager, um,
how did it go? Were you, were
you immediately a attack?
Did your friends all want to
join on board? I mean, what,
what was that like? Yeah.
To just put yourself as
a young person out there.
Because I get so much email now from,
from kids that are in high
school that whatever their is,
they're starting a young libertarian club,
there's nothing and just the amount of
hate that they deal with and all that.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean we definitely got a lot of
rejection, um, because very few people,
like when we were pursuing schools to
give presentations at schools or even
churches meeting,
got rejection from churches because
we want it to go and develop this very
professional presentation
on like the facts. Right.
And we got training and we really did
our research and we developed this whole
program and literally it took a whole
year to convince the first church to let
us come in and give a presentation to the,
to the youth group there. And it took,
you know,
several months and the two years to really
start getting schools to allow us to
come and give presentations.
But we did. Yeah.
Why would you be getting pushback from
churches that I assumed were completely
ideologically aligned?
Well,
just because you're ideologically aligned
in theory doesn't always mean you're
aligned in practice.
So unfortunately,
even in the church and a lot
of Christian communities,
abortion isn't talked about. Um,
women are having abortions. You know,
even some people are encouraging
women to have abortions,
like even pastors and some situations like
privately behind the scenes, you know,
if their daughter gets pregnant.
So there's some really awful
things that happen like that.
And there's this fear of the offense.
It's a fear of offending
their congregation. Um,
or it's just this wanting to be mister
nice guy all the time or Mrs Mrs,
nice guy or a nice girl, whatever. Um,
and so people are afraid to talk
about the tough things, even when,
according to the research
that has been done,
the people who are having abortions,
as many people identify as Protestant or
Catholic as secular and not no religion
who have abortion.
So you have people who are maybe
not going to church every Sunday,
but who have some sort of fake
background who are not really educated.
And not really empowered so that
they're also having an abortion.
So that's part of the battle
is getting this message,
forget what your religious label is,
getting it to people so it
really touches their hearts.
And then you make any inroads
in the church community
to provide the support for
women who faced unexpected pregnancy.
Were you shocked at just how hard it
was just getting the conversation going?
Because the way I always frame
this is if you listen to, you know,
broadly speaking, if you listened to, uh,
how the media deals with this
is if you're on the right,
that means you hate women,
you want to somehow control women.
And if you're on the left and you're pro
choice, that means that you hate babies.
I mean, that's basically how it's
framed and not just through the media.
That's basically how our
politicians are framing it.
How did you find you could sort of get
past just the box that people look at it?
Yes.
Talk to people.
I mean listen than most of our,
most of our impression of what the left
really says on the right really says,
or what abortion act, you know,
advocates supposedly really are saying,
meaning just a normal person who
identifies as pro choice like their
representatives and media.
Um,
versus what we see or what we think are
the representatives for prolife often
displayed in media are not the actual
fullness of the position and they're not
actually dialoguing.
So the benefit of being a teenager at
the time and talking to like sitting down
with the youth pastor or going to the
school administrators and trying to get
inroads was that I was able to just
talk to them as a human to a human and
discuss what we could bring to the
table, discuss, you know, our program.
And it wasn't,
you know,
two people debating in five minutes
segments on a TV show. You know.
So I think when people actually talk
to each other and your communities,
things change, you know, when they
actually have a respectful dialogue.
It doesn't seem that way though.
If you were to watch TV or look at news
headlines because it looks like the
world is so crazy polarized.
Yeah. So, okay. So if we were just sort
of starting from the beginning here,
if you were sitting across from somebody
and let's say they were neither here
nor there on the issue,
they didn't feel strongly either way
or they just wanted more information,
what are some of the things
that you would be telling them?
Sure. So I would start by first of all,
finding the common ground with them.
I would say, you know, do you think,
and I'd ask you Dave, you know,
do you think that it's always wrong
to intentionally take a human life and
innocent human life?
Like is it always wrong to intentionally
take an innocent human life and pretty
much like 99.9% of people,
yeah,
I'm going to wait on answers so that
when we get to ours, our differences,
I think it'll
no, they all say yes.
Yeah. Intentionally wrong,
too indirect to directly take an innocent
human life. And I was like, okay, great.
We all agree.
So number two,
abortion is the intentional and direct
taking of an innocent human life.
And that's usually where we like really.
Tell me more about that.
And then obviously the last conclusion
would be therefore a abortion is always
wrong.
But then we have to unpack all,
why is abortion always the intentional
and direct taking of an innocent human
life? Well, first of all,
we know because science shows us that a
unique individual human life begins as a
single cell embryo at the
moment of fertilization.
Like you and I both
began our life that way.
And from that moment
our sex was determined.
Our eye color or hair
color within three weeks,
our heart started to beat
within six weeks are nervous.
Our brainwaves are starting to,
you know,
that we can be detected
within seven weeks.
So you believe that life
begins at conception?
It's not,
I wouldn't call it a belief,
I'd call it an acknowledgement and
acknowledgement that life begins at
conception. And then we know like you
actually look at abortion procedures,
there's no debate.
I mean they intentionally directly
dismember disembowel destroy that child,
that life, that human life. In the
first, second and third trimester.
So because of those two
facts, you know, abortion,
the intentional taking of an
innocent human life is wrong.
So, okay. So there's a lot of, a
lot of ways we could go here. So,
alright, let, let's do, we'll do some
of the more sciencey stuff first. Um,
in cases where there is a
threat to the mother. Leslie,
we'll just rifle off a few of these.
What,
what position do you think
is right or just or fair?
Yeah,
that's a very good and important question.
And there are certainly
cases where pregnancy can be,
have complications or severe complications
if those were to be the case.
The intentional direct taking of that
innocent human life and abortion is not a
medical treatment.
This is a big confusion that often
happens in kind of pro life pro choice
soundbite debating.
Like we're not actually talking to
each other because they're like, well,
women need abortion for health. And when
you actually unpack it, early delivery.
So in some severe cases, for
example, if there are, um,
ruptured membranes are infected membranes
inside the uterus so that you know
that those are attached to the baby.
In some cases you might have to sit for
severe infections that starting to form,
you might have to deliver the baby early.
That's not an abortion,
that's not targeting the baby's body
for destruction using forceps or using
drugs that's delivering the child because
she's she or he is attached to a part
of a woman's body that's
causing infection. So that
would not be an abortion.
I'm pro life and pro choice agree that
in some cases that may be necessary.
And, but for any other
case, like for example,
if I get chemo or if I get
cancer and I need chemo,
you don't have an abortion,
you might choose to undergo chemo and
that's in targeting the cancer cells might
harm the baby and the baby
there might be miscarriage,
but that's not an abortion.
So you can do any number of treatments
as a woman who's pregnant who might have
complications or may
have other conditions.
But the direct taking of that life going
in there and targeting that baby for
destruction is not a medical treatment.
Right.
So are there no cases where it's a direct
threat to the woman's life that then
there,
there are cases where the things related
to pregnancy might be a threat like for
example,
ruptured or I'm infected membranes,
but that in that situation,
delivering the child early,
that's not going in there to tear
the child apart with, I mean,
the way abortions are done,
abortions aren't done yet.
You're just putting in effect if the
child wasn't ready to be given birth to
right. And that would be a really
tragic case. But in that situation,
there should be careful management of the
pregnancy to try to allow that baby to
live for as long as possible in the womb
so that there would be a chance for the
baby to be delivered alive. But the point
is not using just the, uh, you know,
four Stan, I'd Jay lethal injection
to kill that child before delivery,
but trying to give that child a chance.
And if that child were to die after
delivery because he or she is too premium,
too much of a premium premium keeps
getting pushed back and back as you know,
like 21,
it's 21 weeks now that some babies and
a half that can survive after birth.
It's amazing. They're so teeny, but
we should at least give him a chance.
And that's,
that's it's a total mentality shift.
The mentality shift is are we
going to attempt to save this life,
this life of the child as well as we
treat the mother or are we going to just
say this life is not a life.
Right.
And we can target his or her body
for destruction before birth.
Okay. So that's dealing
with health of the mother.
So what about cases of where its
health of the fetus or of the Child?
So I know somebody within the last year
or so that had an abortion a little bit
after 20 weeks. I think because
the child had severely, severely,
um, uh, under developed brain and the,
and the doctor said this was not going
to be anything remotely close to a,
to a functional life if,
if it survived in the first place.
So where do you stand in a case like that?
I mean,
I would first say if there was a toddler
with a severely underdeveloped brain,
is it okay to take the life of that
toddler because you have a severely
underdeveloped brain or you have even
a life threatening condition that you,
you have a terminal illness.
Does that mean you should be killed?
You know what,
like why don't we treat you with love and
try to eliminate the suffering and not
the sufferer or try to serve the patient
and not see them as somebody that we
can just kill. So I think we just
need a total mentality shift.
And if we acknowledge
that these are humans,
like a toddler or an infant as a human,
if an infant is a human,
then before birth, that
same child, you know,
whether it's weeks or months earlier
in their development is a human.
Humans begat Hume as you can't,
it's not like a different species.
This is a human individual, unique
life. They deserve the same,
they deserve the same care and protection
that an infant does. So we shouldn't,
we don't leave infants to die.
We shouldn't leave infants to today
because they have a life threatening
condition or because they
have a severe disability.
So does the state then,
oh the mother where the parents,
let's say anything. If if the state,
let's say there's someone like this
case I just laid out to you where this
person, they just disagree
with your premise there.
They just feel that they should
be allowed to do what they want,
but then the state says, no,
you cannot have that abortion.
You have to bring this
child into the world.
They fight and now let's
assume that the child survives.
It has all sorts of problems that they
don't want to deal with in the state.
Forced them to, to bring it to term. Yeah.
Do you think there's any responsibility
of the state there? Yeah,
cause this is where I find a little
bit of the conservative argument. Yeah.
To be tough because it's like,
well, okay, I get it. You,
you're trying to protect life.
I can go with you on that.
But then at the same time, if are, if
you're using the state to force that,
well you also don't want the state to
be supporting people and now you have a
little bit of a chasm there in,
in the logic.
Yeah, it's a good question. I say,
first of all, you have to be consistent.
If it is he or she is a life
before birth then and it didn't,
she is a life after birth.
If she's a life after birth,
she's the life he or she has a
life before birth. So you know,
if you're looking at it from the pro
choice perspective of it's not a life,
then you can do whatever you
want. Like I don't, you know,
if you can prove to me this
is not a human life, I'm fine.
You do whatever you want.
Right.
So I think that would be my view.
That would be a pretty
extreme position for I,
I don't find that many people
saying it's not a life after,
but I think that in a of weeks consistent,
if you're a human life,
do you have human rights?
You know,
I think it's just about
consistency and it's about,
so this is the logic side and then I'll
address like what you described as the
compassionate,
but I think we have to be logically
consistent cause we kind of like our,
it's like our brains start turning off.
I think sometimes on this if he or she
is a human life before and science kids
conclusive about that. You know, the, the
United, the United Nations Declaration,
Universal Declaration on
human rights that has,
that all members of the human
family have these rights.
And then an article six that
says that these are, you know,
anybody who's a member of the human
family has a right to be seen as a person
under the law. These are members
of the human family. They smaller,
they're more dependent. They're, they're,
they're, they're very fragile. You know,
they need time in nourishment to grow,
but they're members of the human family,
so they deserve to be treated
that way. Um, but in your city,
in the case you mentioned,
you know, I think it's, uh,
it's obviously very complex because if
you're, if you're like, you know, has,
have socioeconomic struggles,
you're not able to care for it seriously,
a child, a serious disabilities
or a life threatening condition,
you're a terminal illness,
then yes.
I think that there needs
to be a appreciation for
that and in our society or
communities should be supporting
those families. And you know,
if the family is really not able to care
that parents really not able to care,
there should be a way that they can place
their child for adoption or find other
caretakers for that child.
And Yeah.
Don't you think that's
on the state though?
Or do you think that can just be done
with churches and synagogues? Yeah,
I think it's best people closest
and most intimate in the community.
So I'm a big believer in subsidiarity.
So this idea that the best resource are
the best solutions for our community
will be as meant as localized as
possible. Um, that being said,
there will be situations where the
community isn't available or if somebody
fails somebody. And so I do think that
there should be backups. I think that,
you know, I, I think a lot of the systems
we have in place, they're very imperfect,
like, you know, for born
children. Um, for infants,
for children who suffer serious disability
for infants or children from families
that are not taking care of them, you
know, with addictions or abuse. You know,
I think the foster care system needs
a ton of work. I think that, um,
but I'm grateful that it exists.
You know,
I'm grateful that we have some programs,
some state programs.
I think the more localized in,
the more we can empower local communities,
the better. So I'm not against those
things. I think they need to be improved.
But I think those same things should
apply to the child before birth. It's not,
again, we have to be consistent.
If this is a human life, they,
they deserve protection.
Just like a boring life,
whether you're before birth or after.
Yeah. So when we talk about the science
part of this, if, if something in science,
I mean a lot of this has to do
with the way people just view,
I think the nature of reality
and and really, you know
what science verse belief,
I mean it's all here, which is why this
topic is so difficult to talk about.
If science could somehow prove to you
that say that life in essence doesn't
begin until three weeks in,
could that shift your position on this?
MMM.
That you know that the egg meets
the sperm, okay. Conception,
but then for three weeks the
whatever that is at that point,
it actually doesn't qualify as as life
by a sort of technical scientific.
Hmm. I feel like even in the questions,
a little bit of a contradiction,
just because you said three weeks
from something is when life begins.
Well,
three weeks from what?
Well, dude, that's why I brought up the
question because this is where everybody's
definition of everything I think is a,
you know,
you can look at a three week fetus is
obviously very different than what it's
gonna look like at six
months and everything. Yeah,
it's really different as a baby. Like
baby Dave had a massive head as it did.
I write like,
nope,
humans are supposed to look different at
different stages of development. Um, but,
but I think, look, what does the IVF
specialists trying to get in a lab?
What are they obsessed
with getting in there,
trying to create life in a test tube.
They're obsessed with getting the meeting
of us for a minute egg, the fusion,
that moment of fertilization.
Then they have a single cell embryo and
they know that and they'll tell their
client the family we have,
you know, 10 embryos,
you can implant three or
whatever, right? I mean,
they're obsessed with getting that moment,
that special moment in a test you,
because that moment means something and
the, the science on this is conclusive.
But that moment means is you have
a unique individual life that needs
nourishment to grow. So you, it
cannot survive outside the womb.
It can survive outside of the test you,
but it needs,
it needs a ton of support to grow.
But if you give it that support and if
you don't interrupt his or her life,
kill it, then he or she will become
one day, you know, an adult, you know,
one day will grow into, you know, the,
the person and then eventually pass away.
As we all know, we die so that it's
human lifespan. And that's conclusive.
There is that meme that I always find,
it's hard to get my way out of which
it's like they'll show like, you know,
a month old fetus and they'll say that,
you know,
everyone agrees that this is life.
And then they'll show or you know,
or the people on the, you know,
everyone on the right, basically,
we'll agree that this is like people
on the left, we'll say this isn't life.
And then they show, you know, like a speck
of something on Mars and they'll say,
well, you know, all these
scientists say this is life.
And it's like, ah, that's good
human life.
I mean there's a lot of life out there
but we're talking about something very
special, which is human life. And
that's why like even the United Nations,
and I don't know if they're United
Nation fans here, but even they have,
yeah, I'm not a huge fan of the
United Nations generally speaking.
A lot of reasons.
They actually are contradictory
in their policies, but their,
but their principals say, you know,
all members of the human family,
all members of the human family.
So you know, and I think, look,
it's not just right versus left. I think
on this, you know, I'm from California,
I live in Berkeley right now.
I went to school at Ucla,
like I've met people on left
and right who are pro life.
And in the pro life movement there
are atheists, there are secularists.
There are people who are more
left wing who are also pro life.
So this is unfortunately it
seen in the media. And it's art.
It's because the Democratic Party
has like abandoned prolife ideas,
which is really sad because I think you,
there are pro life Democrats out there.
Um, I think a lot of Democrats are
prolife actually the majority of them want
abortion restrictions,
but they're not getting their day.
They're not getting representation.
You know,
they're getting these senators like all
the democratic senators who are running
for office like Kamala, Cory
Booker, Kirsten Gillibrand, uh,
Warren, um, Stanton, Bernie Sanders.
I mean he goes, he's not democratic,
but he basically hit all of them are
the most pro abortion people ever.
They're there for abortion
through all nine months.
Right? So, okay, so let's, let's
bring that to sort of where on that,
because they are making my life
difficult for this because I,
I often describe myself as begrudgingly
pro choice. I view this as,
I think I do this probably as
horrifically a choice as you do.
You don't, you don't think it's
a choice per se, but I view the,
the idea here is as probably
as horrific as you do.
I don't think that something
at 18 weeks is not alive.
So when I discussed this with
ban my Ben Shapiro, my position,
this was I think a little over a year
ago, um, and the clip really took off.
Uh, my position at the time
was that at 20 weeks they've,
there is more than ample evidence that
the fetus can start feeling pain and I
would view that up until that point
that I would leave the choice with the
mother. That, that I, that it's not a
good choice. I'm not defending the choice.
I'm not moralizing about the choice,
but that that's just the position that
I would want the power to be with the
person that is here now.
Now Ben said to me something
that you already alluded
to, which is which if, well,
if you're saying it's a life at 20 weeks,
you're obviously acknowledging it's a
life at 18 weeks and to be logically
consistent,
I had to concede that point because yes,
I am acknowledging that I'm just allowing
the life that's here and now to sort
of supersede in the, in
the decision making. Okay.
Why did, why did we have this
mindset like let's imagine,
I mean there are women that killed
killer infants that are born,
they're born alive infant. I mean
there's just a horrible case in Texas.
This poor girl who you know had gave birth
and stabbed the baby to death and now
she's being tried for murder.
You know that very severe penalties,
which is a whole other debate,
right? But it's like, why do we,
why aren't we consistent on it?
Is it because the infant or the 20 week
old can feel pain is pain that the kind
of ticket to legal protection,
like my ability to feel pain
because what if I was paralyzed?
I couldn't feel pain.
Right? So again, I don't think it's, I
don't think it's a perfectly air tight,
logical argument.
My,
my deference though is to the
mother. Now, I would say this,
and this is why I prefaced it
by what you just did with the,
with the Democrats right now,
is that they have now gone seemingly
so far extreme on abortion,
where it's now we're talking
late trimester and then
there was that really awful
video of the governor of
Virginia, right? Yeah, yeah. Uh,
talking about decisions that could
be made after Bert. Yeah. Yeah.
They've gotten so extreme
that I'm finding, I'm finding,
I'm finding holding what I think
is somewhat moderate position here.
I'm finding to be just very different.
Yeah.
I mean,
I hear you and I think it's because
they're actually being consistent.
That's the thing on, on abortion.
I don't think that you can have a,
when it comes to looking at when life
begins, when life should be protected,
I don't think you can have a moderate,
moderate.
It's either it is a life and
it should be protected here.
She should be protected or he or
she is not a life. And we as adults,
the strong people in the room,
the mom or the the doctor,
we get to decide when that life deserves
protection or when that life can be
killed. So I think that actually in a
way, as as repulsive as the Democrats,
like you know,
crazy abortion through all nine months
and lead the infant to die after birth as,
as crazy it sounds to most people,
they're actually being consistent
because they're saying, well,
it's a helpless dependent infant.
Slash fetus. Slash. Embryo.
I decide as the adult when I can
confer on, you know, the value on this,
I get to make the final medical decision
right as they see at a medical decision.
So leave me alone. Like leave me alone
state, let me do what I want to do.
And it,
yeah,
I think that they're actually
being consistent if they
really think that we have
the right to take some lives.
So how much of this discussion is just
that you think people don't really think
through their positions?
Because like I,
I've thought about this a lot and I get
you, I really, I hear you and I find this,
you know, who knows what I'll, what
I'll think in, in 20 years and we Ryan,
who knows what you'll think in 20 years
or whatever. But that, but that's what,
that's what really thinking through an
issue is about. And, and, and you know,
there's also an irony here because
you know, for someone like myself,
if you take a classical liberal
or libertarian position on this,
you believe in the individual above
anything. So my position has been,
well in the individual, I'm looking
at it through the woman's choice.
Now I get the counter argument. I've heard
this from a lot of libertarians. Well,
if you really believe in the individual,
there's an individual right there,
the fetus is the individual. Um, but how
much of this is just that people don't,
people don't want to do this.
Yeah,
I think it is a lot of that.
I think that most people would
actually come to the pro life position.
And when I say probably position that,
so I think weighted down with
these like political, you know,
edge to it. Like, well that means you're
like a Republican and you love Trump.
If you're pro life, it's like, no,
that's actually not true. You know?
Prolife it says all humans are,
all human lives are precious and
have the same human rights. I mean,
I think that's the, the prolife
platform you could say. Um,
and that starts in the womb obviously,
and it ends at natural death. But I, yeah,
I think a lot more people would be more
open minded and more willing to like
acknowledge human life in the womb and
see the violence of abortion if they had
the conversation. But we just assume
that the other side is wrong, you know,
we assume and, and people, I think when it
comes to prolife, if they're pro choice,
they assume that's just what the
crazy Republicans believe, you know?
Or that's what Trump thinks or that's
what Trump is doing. Or you know, they,
they don't really,
and then they're afraid.
I think that's the other thing is fear.
People are afraid.
And even what you were saying Dave,
about being moderate on this,
I think there's a sphere of like
women are going to be set back,
like mothers are going to be
set back if abortion is illegal,
if abortion is rejected.
Societaly yeah,
right.
Well it's always framed as a woman's
right issue or a woman's health issue.
Right,
right.
Which is extremely misleading
because I mean the first I,
the a key part of the hippocratic
oath on healthcare is do no harm.
And actually the original
hippocratic oath,
which is that all doctors and medical
personnel had to take this oath saying
that they would actually not administer
abortion because abortion is doing harm
to the second patient, to the, to
the child. It's killing that child.
So we have to have a paradigm shift on
this and we also have to see that there
are risks, there is responsibility
that is involved. I mean,
I'm not saying that any
woman who gets pregnant,
she has to parent that child and be
involved in that child's life for life
because that's, you know, that may be
something that's really difficult for her,
something that she's not able to do,
but I think we need to take more
responsibility for each other.
I think that's part of the message.
So then going back to the
question that I asked earlier,
do you think that a sensible thing for
the pro life movement to do that today,
and this is a strange hint that
I might be giving you, would be,
would be you focusing
more on what's done after.
So we framed that before within,
whether it's done through the church
or some other private organization,
but if the focus was there so that you
can take the pressure off all of the men
and women who, you know, they're
sort of somewhere in the middle,
but they are really concerned that if
you're going to force people to do this,
you're going to bring all these unwanted
pregnancies and all of these things out
there and then you're going to have, or
you're going to have more women, you know,
going to back alleys and all that. So
that, so that if your focus may be,
was there a little bit more maybe,
maybe that would do something.
I'm really just speaking.
Yeah, I mean that is the product
movements focus. I mean, again,
this is totally the misrepresentation.
I think of our,
of our work and, and at the movements work
to people who disagree. I mean, again,
people who disagree are likely not going
to be getting their news from people
who are pro life.
People who disagree are going to be
getting their news from organizations like
the New York Times is pro abortion.
I mean the,
The Washington Post editorial
boards or pro abortion,
they explicitly aren't
supportive abortion.
Do you know you're not going to get me to
defend mainstream media here right now.
You're just giving me red man.
Mine is that you don't know what's
going on in the product movement because
people haven't taken the time to look.
The pro life movement has thousands more
than, uh, more than abortion clinics,
thousands of pro bono,
confidential pregnancy and early
childhood care support facilities.
You know, places where they provide
prenatal support, they provide ultrasound,
they provide parenting
classes, baby clothes, diapers,
and then when the child is still an infant
that we'll try to help place for jobs.
They'll try to do resume work,
they'll do all kinds of amazing things
and there's thousands of pregnancy
centers across the country
that are designed for this.
Then the social safety nets that we do
have in this country are designed for,
for, for young mothers and for
young families as well. Those,
those exist churches that
are doing support, you know,
connected to pregnancy care centers.
So there's a ton of stuff out there like
here in la, there's several of them.
And I volunteered at them, you know, when
I was a student. So they're out there,
they're just not getting any press.
Yeah. People just don't know about them.
So about the, so we do care. We care
about where you have to be consistent.
I agree. You're pro life,
you can't just be like,
I just love the baby before he or
she is born. We love the baby period.
We love the life period.
And there's work being done for
children both before and after birth.
Yeah. So what about the sort of like
nitty gritty legal parts of this?
Cause the, the discussion about abortion
often is just framed through Roe v Wade,
right? So we're, well, I don't
have to ask you where you fall off,
where you fall on Roe v Wade, but it
is one of those positions where, again,
and I say this is begrudgingly pro choice
and I hear you and I, and I hear it. I,
I really, I do hear you on these
arguments. I really do. Um,
but as a state's rights guy,
because everyone's, everyone,
a lot of people think that Roe v
Wade was about making abortion legal
[inaudible], which isn't the case. This
was it, that it was federally, right? Uh,
mandated so that,
okay,
stripped away states protections the
roadway way basically said you can't ban
abortion in your state. You're not
allowed to abortion as a right. You can,
you need to allow abortions. And that's
actually part of the, the, the uh,
women's right in your state. And
look, I mean, you could do this,
you could kind of walk back to another
human rights abuse, our country,
a profit at both profited
from and perpetuated, which
is slavery. And you know,
you had this, this, this situation where
you had some states who saw the, the,
the uh, the person, the slave
as three fifths of a human,
literally three fifths of a person. And
then you saw some states who said, no,
these are persons.
I don't think states should get to decide
that some humans are persons and other
humans aren't persons. I'm
with everybody's a person.
If you're a human life,
you're a person.
Now how we care for you and protect you.
It's going to be complex. That's, that's
a whole other question, but I don't,
I'm about, I'm also for
states' rights. You know,
I think we're very big diverse country.
I think localization is important
for laws and for, you know,
both was safety nets, you know,
community, how communities are governed.
But I don't think that we should get to
decide whether some people live or die.
I mean, that's what it, it's
interesting because this is where,
because we don't have these conversations
and if you don't hear people explain
that properly because you hear
a lot of people on the right,
we'll say that they think
it's an overstep, uh,
by the court of what the constitution
should be laying out in terms of state's
rights and the individual and all that.
You're saying that even though
your first state's rights,
that you don't even think
this is a states rights issue?
Yeah. I mean, again, it
all comes back to is he,
is he or she or human life and do all
human lives deserve protection? I mean,
again,
I know it's hard to be,
it's hard to be consistent in that way
because we have these competing concerns,
especially ones that have been
heavily branded and promoted,
like this idea of women's rights, this
idea of choice. I'm for women's rights,
by the way.
I am for choice.
I'm for bodily autonomy to the degree
that I'm not interfering with somebody
else's right to live.
But again,
I can't interfere with
somebody else's right to live.
And if I have a child with me,
that is a responsibility.
I do have to a degree at least, and other
people should be helping me with it,
but that doesn't mean I have the
right to end the of that child.
Okay, so let's go to just
some other series. The
unpleasant parts of this, when,
when we see videos of what an abortion
is like and all of these things,
and undercover planned parenthood things
where they talk about, yeah, you know,
throwing body parts into a guard. I mean,
horrible, horrible stuff. Yeah. I just, I,
I guess I want to give you an
opportunity to just address some of that.
Obviously not that shocking to you,
what's going on?
Yeah, well, I've been inside
abortion clinics. I mean,
I've done investigative reporting
and I know people, you know,
obviously David has done
the investigative reporting,
exposing the body parts, trafficking,
that happens at abortion facilities. Um,
he and I work together, so I'm very
familiar with that really ugly side of it.
Yeah.
So what does that actually mean?
That they're actually aborting fetuses
and then selling the body parts? Yeah,
yeah, exactly. I mean, now they would say
we don't make that much money off of him,
so it's not really selling, but they're
making like 70, 80, $90 a body part.
And if you've got five body parts, if
you've got a heart, a Le Livre, a brain,
you know, you could be making
400 $500 off of each fetus,
off of each baby and on top of
the 500 or 400 or $600 abortion,
they're talking about a thousand bucks
plus an abortion, then, you know,
all in profit or all in net,
you know, money coming in.
So it is an industry. Um,
the government's funding it,
people don't realize this,
but the National Institute
for Health has a budget.
$100 million in the last reported year
goes to research on aborted baby body
parts. So think about that. Like the
government is literally have this,
he has this hundred, you know, 100
million bucks, millions of dollars,
which is for these researchers.
And so they're going to go by,
they need their stuff, they need
their body parts. So where do they go?
Abortion facilities. And they're
going to be like, you know,
it's profitable for the abortion facility
to do business with the middleman who
then hands it off to the, to
the experiment. You know, the,
the person experimenting on these,
on these children's bodies
where, where does planned
parenthood fit into the equation?
So they sell, um, they've sold body parts
and there's continue to sell body parts.
In fact,
the district attorney here in Orange
County shut down the middle man that was
doing business with planned parenthood
to by body parts from them to then sell
them off to medical experimenters, you
know, who are doing experimentation on,
on them. So planned parenthood is one
of, I mean they're the biggest abortion.
China,
I mean a lot of people don't know this
about planned parenting cause they were
like planned parenthood,
you know?
Yeah. Awesome. They're a hoe. You
always hear people say play. It's,
it's less than 1% of their
activities or something like that.
Even the Washington Post has given
that three Pinocchios, you know,
like slate has called it very misleading
that they do one, you know, one or 3%.
Um, the fact is planned parenthood
is the biggest abortion providers.
So there they commit over
300,000 abortions annually.
That's almost a third of the
national abortion rate. Um,
they're the biggest kind of single
chain that is doing abortions.
That's 900 a day.
900 lives taken a day up to 24 weeks.
So even past the point you
say, are your, you know,
okay with these are children that are
viable. Um, but all of the abortions are,
are wrong or are taking
innocent human lives.
And that's a lot of dead bodies that
they could do business with middlemen to
get them off to labs where
they're experimented on.
Is there any country in the west that are,
that's doing the laws in a better way,
a better way of within your estimation.
So Malta, Malta has, you know,
really better much talk a little bit
ever been referenced on the show before.
Well, go Malta. You know, I'm also really
prolife and they're very, you know,
no abortion is permitted in the country.
Um,
Ireland was very prolife
until abortion activists,
a lot of them imported from the UK and
from other countries when there and said,
no, this is gonna be, we
gotta legalize it. But let's
see, let's just back up this.
So a country like Malta,
are there numbers on how many women are
now actually going to back alleys and,
and what is actually the state doing
after? And that's a great question Dave,
because I think that is a,
a fear that motivates like abortion
pro choice people sometimes like,
well women are going to go to back alleys.
That's actually a myth.
That's actually a myth that
all these women are going
to do back alley abortions.
If abortion's illegal before abortion
was illegal, let's legal in this country,
the abortion that suppose,
um,
deaths from back alley
abortions were in the hundreds,
not the tens of thousands
that were claimed. And the,
the reason we know this is first of all,
the CDC was reporting in the hundreds
but tens of thousands that were claimed
that they said we'll tens of thousands
of women are dying right now. Um,
were fabricated numbers and the people
that made up those numbers later on
admitted it.
So Dr. Bernard Nathan said it was
important abortionist he helped found the
national abortion rights association.
So Ne Rao and he later became a pro
life activists, this guy. And he said,
we made up the numbers. We were just
trying to like get our agenda through.
So we literally made statistics up out of
thin air. What was it that changed him?
I'm sure there's an interesting story.
I mean,
there are a lot of things that
changed him, but eventually,
cause he's doing all these abortions
and eventually he just saw and you know,
as he was looking at the ultrasound of
what he was doing and the child basically
running for his or her life, I mean, from
the section, he just was like, I can't,
this is all of a sudden it
clicked for him. I mean,
it's kind of a mysterious thing.
Why didn't it click before?
But it clicked for him and he just
thought, I can't do this anymore.
And at the same time he was having his
own faith journey and like believing that
human life is made by a god,
a creator who loves us.
And that also was beginning
to move his heart on it. Um,
but so it took them years to kind of have
a full, like, you know, one 80 on it.
But eventually he became, you know,
a pro life activists and said,
I was a mass murderer. You know, he wrote
books about his experience and said, I,
you know, I, I took 70,000
lives and shared that fountain.
So we discussed a little bit about the
belief part and you mentioned that there
are nonbelievers that are prolife
you really never hear about that.
Do you find that they have different
issues that they're thinking about or
struggling with or meaning if you're
not have a religious background? Yeah,
cause yeah,
the general picture of someone that's
prolife is usually just like a Christian
conservative. I mean that's just,
yeah, that's generally what it is.
You don't find that many or you just
don't see publicly that many atheist or
just more secular prolife people.
Yeah. Well first of all, I
wasn't always identify as,
I didn't always identify as a Christian,
you know,
when I was like in high school and as a
teenager I actually ended up becoming a
Catholic in college.
But it was after my own journey of
discovering what I believed and whether I
knew for sure what religion
identified with, if at all.
I knew that it was wrong to intentionally
taken innocent human life. So I think,
again, if it goes back
to the, the, the, the,
the facts of this and it goes back
to the, you know, being consistent.
It doesn't matter your worldview, it
doesn't matter your religious background.
It doesn't even matter
your political affiliation.
Nothing matters except do
you believe human life is,
it should not be intentionally killed,
innocent human life and is the child in
the womb is this innocent human life. Um,
but that being said,
I think there is a growing amount of
people even in the pro life movement who
don't identify with a religion, who
are, you know, atheists, I know these,
some of them, firstly atheists
or, um, part of, uh, you know,
very left leaning causes other causes
who are pro life and see it from a
scientific and logical perspective and
from a human rights perspective. Um,
but there are a lot of, obviously
people of faith who are pro life.
I wish there were more
just because you know,
there are people of faith who are out
there being Christian and they're not
doing anything about pro, you
know, abortion there, you know,
this is the greatest human rights issue.
The,
there are thousands of children
being killed every day and,
and women facing an unexpected
pregnancy at churches.
And it's not talked
about enough in churches.
So just because you're a Christian or
conservative doesn't mean you've got it
all figured out.
You know,
have you found,
um,
counterparts on the pro choice side
of this that are willing to have this
discussion? Because originally when,
when I think you reached out to us,
or maybe it was on Twitter at first
about coming on the show, I thought,
all right,
well I should do this one as a debate.
And then I thought about it a little bit
longer and I thought, you know what? No,
let's, let's do one just with you so we
can hear your ideas without it, you know,
without the entering the fray.
And then I'll find somebody who it will
be a lot easier to find someone on on
that side. Right. Um, and do that.
And then maybe we'll do this as a debate
then or a conversation or something.
Yeah.
And I'd be happy to do it but I wanted
to do it separately first just so that
all the ideas can be out there.
Do you find that you can find people on
the pro choice side of this that will
debate you in this? In an honest and even
way, because I don't have to tell you,
I'm finding it harder and harder to find
people broadly on the left that will do
these types of debates without attacking
you personally and your motives.
And that's really hard things about it.
It's really hard,
Dave, to find people willing
to debate about this.
I have been on shows like radio shows,
TV shows,
and planned parenthood has been invited
and every time they've declined like
planned parenthood spokespeople
or representatives.
And I was actually on a live radio show.
It was somewhere in the Midwest and
the planned parenthood director of that
Midwest affiliate was on the
other line like she had been,
she had been invited and when she heard
my voice and she heard that who I was
like as a pro life activists and she
heard me talking, she literally hang,
hung up like she, she ditched out
of this, you know, ditch the show.
So I have seen in the pro abortion world,
um,
I call it pro abortion because
I don't think, again there's,
there is middle ground on this,
but in that pro choice world I've,
it's very hard to find people
willing to have the debate,
especially on live TV or in a longer
you a format where it's filmed or people
can watch it later.
Yeah. It's so interesting because that I
just find so consistent with everything
that's happening on the left
these days on every issue.
If you want to talk about climate change,
they won't talk about it cause you
have to accept their position first or
whatever.
And again,
I say that I say that as someone that's
not fully where you are obviously,
but like I'm finding it more difficult
and more difficult than their stake.
They're in an odd way,
they're staking out religious position.
Yeah. It's a, it's interesting. It's
like, it's the new pharisees, you know,
it's like, I'm so holy, I'm so right.
I'm not even gonna deal with your dirty,
you know, people that don't just don't
agree with me and like, you know, I'm,
I'm the one who's pure.
I'm the one who's compassionate.
I'm the one who's correct.
And yeah,
it's really vicious and it's
really bad for everybody, you know.
What do you think the pro life community
generally thinks of Trump at this point?
I mean,
he's probably in a weird way,
been the biggest supporter for you
guys in modern times at some level,
right?
Yeah. I mean, he has been very
supportive and in many ways, um,
I was very skeptical when
he ran for office. Um,
I did not vote for him in the primary.
Um, and I was really concerned.
I thought he was potentially
just kind of tricking.
All of us are trying to trick people.
You know,
even when he had my pants come on as the
VP because of Penn's a super pro life
and he has been consistently politically
for years. Um, I was encouraged by that,
but I was also like, is
this like your token prolife
pence, you know, on a ticket.
But he has eve ministration has
done some very prolife things,
which I'm really grateful for.
I find it really sad though that,
you know, the, the one that's most
prolife as far as the policy is concerned,
you know, he, he did it, he
reversed the Mexico City policy,
which is international funding for
abortion. He um, defunded planned. Yeah.
Let's talk about that one for a second.
Cause that was actually,
I think one of the first things that he
did and it sort of went under the radar
and, and then I saw these people
arguing about it and it's like,
so we were actually funding
abortions overseas, not overseas,
but in Mexico over, over,
not beyond our borders.
For some reason we were using
American tax dollars to do that.
Do we even know why? Why was that
policy even in place in the first place,
that that has nothing to do with
whether you're pro choice or pro life.
That's just like,
why are we funding abortions anywhere?
Why are we funding these types
of things outside of work?
Yeah, I mean a population control is a
lot of it and that is rooted in Eugenics.
So early you,
Dennis s in this country,
we're also Margaret
Sanger and her friends,
she founded planned parenthood
and they wanted to use,
they used for sterilization,
like she promoted for
sterilization. Margaret Sanger,
who is the founder of planned parenthood.
She actually designed
the one child policy.
She wrote out a proposal for a
one child policy. If you were,
apparently you're not allowed
to have more than one child,
the state would force you
to only have one offspring.
And that's what China's doing right now.
I mean,
they've kind of expanded it to maybe
the two child policy, but it's,
it's really horrific.
I mean it's this idea that the
government gets to decide what happens in
reproduction.
So it's the whole thing about pro choice.
It's actually the opposite of it. It's
like, so not choice that you are not,
you're forced abortion,
forced sterilization and if
somebody's developing nations.
I know the stories and these
are anecdotal so we don't,
it's hard to even know the full body of
research on this or no what is actually
going on,
but I have anecdotal stories of women
who went to family planning clinics in
Mexico or family planning clinics in some
African nations that are UN operated,
funded by us,
have been in the past month by us tax
dollars and they were without their
consent or knowledge we're given IUD
is placed in them that they then didn't
know how to deal with. I
mean they would, you know,
years later this one woman had migraines
yet had all these health conditions.
You didn't know what was wrong with her.
Finally they discovered this old IUD
in here that have been there in her for
like 15 years and with potentially
it could be life threatening.
So there's all kinds of weird
stuff happening where the rich,
right. I suppose that depends how far you
want to go down the rabbit hole of what
these, the ritual eat may be in
you and are doing about, yeah.
They're like looking at impoverished
countries and they're thinking, hmm,
what are we going to do with impoverished
countries or countries that are
struggling? Let's have them make
sure they have less children.
Like why not better education,
access to clean water,
better infrastructure, less,
you know, better democracies.
Why don't we just going to try to kill
off or limit their ability to have
children?
I mean it's,
it's a really a terrible
approached at a very, very,
I think in many ways it's
racist and it's, and it's, it's,
it's of discriminatory just because
people are poor against them, right?
Because you're poor,
you shouldn't have children.
Right. It's one of
those things, I mean to,
to be funding these
things beyond our borders,
the United State for remove the unit,
you end for a second, but to, you know,
for the United States to be doing it,
it's such a strange thing.
Then our, our borders. I mean, well,
whether you,
whether you're for it or not,
doing something within
your borders is one thing.
Doing something outside of your borders.
Yeah. I mean it's our, it's
our, I think, you know,
where they were going to go save the
world. America is going to save the world.
Yeah.
America can do good in the world for sure.
But you're not saving the world by going
off and helping other people kill their
offspring. I mean, that's just not good.
So what is the funding situation? So,
yeah, so I, I you hear a lot about this,
about how much we either give
a tax dollars for abortions
and planned parenthood
or they'll say no,
it's 99% private are extremely
confusing information that,
that again, it's one of these things,
it depends who you follow on Twitter to,
to basically decide what you
think on this. So what is,
what do we need to know about fun?
Yeah. So here are the basic
numbers. And again, I, I'll,
I'll explain what the opposing side
may say. So for, for, you know,
maybe show where the disconnect is,
but there's over half of $1 billion
being going to planned parenthood from
taxpayer us tax payer sources.
So that's federal money and it's shifting,
you know,
going down through the states being
distributed through title, title 10,
historically that's what president
Trump just cut actually, um,
his administration and through Medicaid
largely there's all these other teeny
little pockets dreams, you know,
the streams of money as well.
So planned parenthood
says, well, we're not,
they're not funding our abortion because
we're using this to reimburse for
ultrasound or reimburse for condoms
are reimbursed for, you know, um,
a pregnancy test or whatever.
The problem with that is those
reimbursements are helping fund the
infrastructure at planned parenthood where
they're committing abortions and some
of those other services like ultrasound
or pregnancy tests are done around the
abortion service.
No,
it was like the precursor base.
Yeah. And it's just the money's
fungible. Like, you know,
it's kind of like saying like,
we're not going to fund the funds steak,
you know,
people eating steak because it's wrong.
It's eating cows is wrong or you know, or
turning the environment whenever. Right,
right. Um, and so we're not, we're,
but we're still gonna fund steakhouses
half of a billion dollars a year.
It's like, well, it's only paying for the
ketchup and the French fries and like,
you know, it's just like,
come on guys like that.
It is funding a corporation
that has increased abortion
numbers over the last 10
years and a lot of their other
services have actually declined. Okay.
Is there any other funding that the
u s provides that outside of planned
parenthood?
You mean to abortion
provider? Yeah, not typically,
unless they find ways to reimburse for
similar things at planned parenthood is
doing. So there's, there is a
Hyde amendment where in some,
I actually take that back because
in some states like California,
you can reimburse directly from abortion.
So that's the state money.
So we're just talking federal money
this half of a billion dollars. Um,
so planned parenthood, if you went to
a planned parenthood in California,
if you qualify,
you could reimburse for an abortion,
even a late term abortion in our state and
other states. Um, so that's, uh, that's,
uh,
a big chunk of money and it's hard to
even track that money because every state
tracks it differently. But, but yeah,
I think the fact that they're funding the
infrastructure for planned parenthood,
they're funding the ability
for it to market itself,
build relationships in communities. Um,
you know, put the, turn the lights on,
hire the staff. It all helps them
increase their abortion business.
Do you know that numbers are the
specifics on like states that, right.
So I get your position on Roe v Wade.
I would assume a state like Mississippi
still probably has the tightest laws
around when you can have an abortion
versus a state that I suppose like
California, that probably the most
lenient and I'm just picking those two,
but I'm guessing I'm not that far
off. Yeah, there are gravity is right.
Like for example,
Ohio recently passed the heartbeat bill,
which would try to ban abortions
once the heartbeat can be detected.
The problem is,
yes,
usually.
When is that?
That's it. Just three, you know, three
weeks basically 21 days. Amazing.
I'll quickly like it. Most women don't
know they're pregnant at that point. They,
they,
they like don't even have even necessarily
missed her period yet or they might
just start to be missing
it. Um, so anyways, yeah,
I think there are states that are trying
to ban abortions like past the first
trimester in the first trimester,
but they're being hit with challenges
because that's where row kicks in,
you know, row says and row and dough
dough, which are two different cases.
And then Casey v Planned parenthood,
these different illegal precedents
after Roe that basically say if you're a
state,
it's really hard for you to ban or
nearly impossible for you to ban abortion
after, you know, before
viability. Um, or if you prefer,
do you mind for them that then the
discrepancy is when is viability? Right,
right. And that meant, you know,
medical advancements have pushed it
further and further back. You know,
a child can survive at
21 and a half weeks.
It's incredible of who
was born completely.
Primi and that may continue to push back.
But again, it's so arbitrary. It's like,
why does that define whether or not
you should live or die? You know,
how advanced medical technology is,
whether or not you can be killed or not.
So you would argue that
then this law in Ohio,
the heartbeat lies basically you would
say that's a good first step or something.
Yeah.
Yeah. We, we celebrate
any of any laws like that.
And there are some states which are also
trying to limit abortion by making it,
making abortion facilities have
to have standards like hospitals.
So that's another thing that is made some
progress. And what standards does that,
for example, ambulatory hallway,
so you're able to fit your, uh,
you know, I, I, um,
a stretcher through the hallway so
that if there's a woman who starts
hemorrhaging, which has happened, you
know, happens sometimes with abortion,
she can be carried on a structure,
um,
or the doctor has to have visiting
privileges, uh, in nearby hospitals.
So if she goes to the
emergency room afterwards,
I mean I just knew a friend who recently
had to go to the emergency room, um,
who had an had an abortion and you need
to have the doctor be able to accompany
you or know who your doctor is, have
admitting privileges. But again,
abortion advocates are
against all of these things.
They think abortion facilities basically
should have as few regulations.
That's like a dental clinic or even less
actually like a tanning. So on, you know,
because again, it's this
idea, this ideology,
this is a women's rights don't
interfere whatsoever. And you know that
probably what state,
what state is the most lenient if
Ohio is sort of doing it right.
In your estimation, what stay would you
say is sort of the most out there? Okay.
Well,
New Mexico's really out there.
It's abortion through all
nine months for any reason.
So that really is real. So you, that means
that you can have a perfectly healthy,
yeah,
eight months.
Yeah. Fetus. Yes.
And you don't have to have a medical
excuse. You don't have to have a, yeah,
I mean I, yeah, I mean this
is where I just, I can't,
and I got nothing left there,
right.
Like,
yeah. I mean it's happening. People
don't even know when New York. Huh.
Are there numbers on
how often that happened?
Say after it's really hard after that,
20 weeks or something like that. Yeah.
It's really hard to track.
We know it's in the tens of thousands,
but it's hard to know exactly.
You know,
cause it's some of the state reporting
that California doesn't report to the CDC
how many abortions it does or how late
term they are. So the national numbers,
I mean we know tens of thousands,
but we don't know. Beyond that,
we don't know what else is
happening in some of these dates.
What New York did is already
being done in seven other states,
abortion through nine months. But we
just, again, people just don't know.
Media is not reporting on it.
Wait, so the New York thing, which
just happened and there's a very,
I thought it was a very chilling video.
I mean,
I tweeted it even though I
wasn't thrilled to do it,
of all of the state legislator legislature
of cheering this bill so that that
bill allowed it under any
circumstances to nine months
in New York. They said, well,
if there's a health or what could be
emotional health or mental health reason,
economic reason that the
mother and the doctor decides.
So that's really saying if for any reason,
because if I go in and say,
we know I'm not feeling like doing this
because I just think it's not convenient
for my life right now. Um, it's
not good for my life right now.
And you got the abortion as a
sign off on it, which, you know,
they're making up to $20,000 for a late
term abortion, then you're good to go.
Okay
man. It's unbelievable. And
then they had the, the uh,
statute and that statue of Liberty,
the empire state building is in pink or
something because we're all trade the
new world trade building built
it. It was lit up and pink. Yeah.
To celebrate the late term
abortion passage. I mean,
this is where I say it's
like they're making my,
what I would again say is a pretty
moderate yeah, decision and you know,
you're saying they're 21 weeks now
because science has advanced that a,
that a fetus could be, uh, you know, uh,
livable, right? Then it's like, all right,
well I'm talking about the 20
week pain thing and if I that had,
I could probably,
if we did this long enough,
you could get me to move forward on
that and that they will know, well,
let's say it's 16 weeks.
And again,
I'm conceding that because that was the
exact conversation I had with Ben when
he said, well, if it's at 18 weeks
and I can't, I can't deny that.
But then when they take
such an extreme position,
and I think this is what's happening all
over the political landscape right now,
we have sides taking stress,
extreme positions all over the place.
So we get pulled in ways that
maybe aren't the default.
I places for us that's true about
policy decisions, like how do we
deal with environmental concerns?
How do we deal with health care?
How do we deal with tax palsy?
What do we do about the poor?
What do we do about homeless?
It's like there's so many,
what do we do about education?
You can have extreme policy positions,
but with prolife it's not about policy.
It's about fundamentals.
It's about do human beings have the
right to live and does the state,
is it the state's duty to do
their best to protect them,
even if it's a complex situation. Because
in a situation where you know there's,
for example, a child abuse, right? If
a family is abusing their children,
the state isn't inspecting every home
to see if your child abuse is happening.
Right? So similarly, if
we made abortion illegal,
it's not like the state's going to be
inspecting every pregnancy. They're there.
We'll have to,
we'll have to deal with it.
We'll have to deal with
that complex situation.
But it comes back to are we
about protecting human rights,
the right to life or not?
And that's why with prolife,
I don't really see it as
one extreme versus another.
I actually see the Democrats position
right now of abortion through all nine
months as the logical,
consistent argument coming from this
idea that human life in the womb does not
have value,
does not have legal rights.
Right? So you're really giving the devil
his due there. You're saying, all right,
this is what you guys want and
this actually all makes sense.
Doesn't have legal protection at 19 weeks.
Why should it have legal protection at 20?
All right, so one more for you and then
I promise you we will do this. If I,
if I can get someone that will have this
conversation in good faith, we will,
we will absolutely do it. And
I welcome people to, you know,
give us some recommendations
in the comments below. Um,
what kind of costs is this
ad for you to just do this?
This is not the type of thing that you're
going to get invited to the parties at
Berkeley and the cool parties
in la and everything else.
Just putting yourself out there
on something. The, I, you know, I,
I know about getting hate online.
What does this cost you?
Yeah, I mean, I've gotten my share of
hate online over the years and you know,
death threats and weird attacks and
stockers and just very, you know,
fake porn websites set up about me and
just very weird things over the last 10
years doing this activism and doing
reporting on this. Um, but you know,
it all kind of, I put it all in
perspective because I think, look,
we live in one of the freest and most
prosperous nations despite these horrible
blights that we're struggling with.
Like with, in the past it was slavery.
In the past it was,
you know,
women not even having equal rights under
the wise men. And now we have abortion.
So we are dealing with are crap. We
have, we have this stuff to deal with,
but I feel very privileged. And so
when I do experience attacks, I put it,
it helps me to put it in
perspective, you know? Um,
and then also just the incredible reward
of seeing lives being saved. I mean,
I've been privileged to see lives being
saved because of the work that we do.
Like women who learned the facts and
they'll say, I could never do this.
I've just not going to have an abortion.
I'm canceling my appointment and we get
pictures of like the newborn and you
don't understood, or were you just
like third graders start crying?
Like thank you know, thankful,
thank goodness that this happened.
Like thank God this happened.
So it's incredibly rewarding because
we're dealing with life and death,
but so it's extremely painful because
we're dealing with really horrific
violence,
but we're also seeing lives
be born and live and thrive.
And that's what it's all about.
So this is what it's all about for me.
I mean,
this is exactly why I do this show and
I'm thrilled that you came in here and
we'll continue this conversation.
And, uh, for more, I Laila,
you can follow her on
Twitter at Lila Grace Rose
[inaudible]
okay.